the prime minister has been asked to
return to the commons to correct
comments he made
over the government's covert 19 advice
on care homes
boris johnson claimed that the
government never told care homes
that residents were unlikely to get the
disease despite
zakir sama reading the official guidance
out him during prime minister's
questions
until the 12th of march the government's
own official advice was
and i'm quoting from it it remains very
unlikely
that people receiving care in a care
home will become
infected yesterday's ons figures
showed that at least 40 percent of all
deaths from covert 19
were in care homes does the prime
minister accept that the government was
too slow to protect people in care homes
prime minister uh no mr speaker
it wasn't true that the uh advice say it
said that and actually
uh we brought the lockdown in uh care
homes
ahead of the of the general lockdown and
what we've seen is a concerted action
plan to tackle what has unquestionably
been
an appalling epidemic in care homes and
a huge exercise in testing is going on a
further 600 million pounds i can
announce
today for infection control in care
homes
well shortly after the session the
labour leader wrote this letter to boris
johnson asking him to return to the
commons to correct the record
sigistarma also urged the government to
accept it's been too slow
to properly protect care homes sky's
chief political correspondent john craig
joins us now live from westminster and
are we going to see the prime minister
back in the house today
oh i doubt it very much uh uh boris
johnson will no doubt uh claim that
uh the leader of the opposition was
quoting selectively
it was uh an uncomfortable pm cues for
mr johnson
you'll have noticed there the nearest mp
to him was matt hancock the
uh health secretary we made this point
last week after pm cues
one of the uh one of the perils for the
prime minister or any other minister
answering questions in the house
is of course the two meter rule now
normally you would have a
front bench packed with ministers and
the parliamentary private secretary
behind the pm able to pass notes a
minister able to whisper in the prime
minister's
ear i mentioned last week when david
cameron was prime minister
george osborne always sat right next to
him was prompting him the whole time
boris johnson hasn't got any of that
he's looked around once or twice
for help almost really um but uh he does
appear to have been caught out the uh
the exp the explanation as i've said
from number 10
is that sake was quoting selectively
however
in this letter uh which you've just
shown jane
uh he says uh at that at this time of
national crisis it's more important than
ever that government ministers are
accurate
in the information they give uh given
this i expect you to come to the commons
at the earliest opportunity to correct
the record
and recognize this was official
government guidance
regarding care homes and he does say
very significantly
i'm copying this letter to the speaker
of the house of commons now the speaker
is not
best pleased with mr johnson at the
moment uh he has on a number of
occasions uh
ticked him off uh for uh first of all uh
making his big announcement on tv on
sunday
rather than coming to the house of
commons and then also he ticked him off
on monday when he did come
for going on too long in his statement
so
what is probably going to happen is that
uh
time will lapse uh if there is no uh uh
no statement from the pm we may get a
reply to uh
mr sakirshama's letter but if labour
feels it's not
adequate they will no doubt raise a
point of order in the chamber
although the house is rising today until
next monday
and uh given the mood he's in and the
way he feels disposed towards the pm at
the moment
it may well be that the speaker rather
than the leader of the opposition orders
uh mr johnson to come back if indeed it
is shown
uh that uh he did mislead the house
misleading the house of course is uh
very very much frowned upon and can get
politician into a lot of trouble
john thanks very much